herzlich kommt zu diesem video leute ihr
seht wir beginnen dieses video in dem
gewohnten setting machen heute aber
keine action denn er hat schon gesehen
ich werde für 24 stunden einen hund
adoptieren als info vorneweg preschen
seien interessiert der hund heißt sam
und das ist der wg hund von der wg von
der freundin von meinem bruder
daher kann ich ihn auch wir haben schon
ein paar mal miteinander gespielt ich
glaub zwar mag mich auch ein bisschen
ich mal gehen auf jeden fall sehr
vermissen sheltie wie auch besser hin
werdet wie gesagt haben kennt mich schon
ich habe schon ein paar mal mit ihm
gespielt waren zusammen gassi gehen ich
war auch schon ein zwei mal mit dem
joggen was auch gut ist glaube ich beim
experiment dass der hund nicht mehr
komplett fremden personen anvertraut
wird für diese 40 stunden aber wir haben
ja noch nie annähernd so viel zeit
miteinander verbracht inklusive
übernachtung und allem drum und dran
deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt was
passiert ist er wird jetzt gleich vorbei
gebracht und ich würde sagen jetzt auch
leute da kommt darf ich weiß es noch
nicht rausspringen davor dem auto sind
drucken und er freut sich wenn ich mal
ausmachen
ich erkannte ich heute mal vier tage er
hat für jedes bisschen gebraucht hieß es
ich glaube herr wulff r wird von der
glaube ich ein bisschen wenn man drauf
hat als mensch sollte wird sich erst mal
zum max rein formal bisschen an und dann
überlegen was heute machen man muss auch
dazu wissen heute dass er küsst sehr
gerne in einen menschen lecker schmecken
wir müssen erst mal richtig hallo sagen
hey das aber jemand für energie wird ich
habe mich schon mal gedanken macht was
wir heute machen könnt und zwar hat
möchte ich dir einen trick beibringen
wir bringen den trick breiter und lag
dabei mit lächerlichen und natürlich wie
immer gas gehen spielen das haben wir
auch eine übernachtung
ich habe eine gute zeit kommt bald der
dominiert ist ja ich bin der
basketball-em oder englischer zum falls
ich wundere mich englisch redet da wird
man den autofahrer aufgeregt wo ist dein
hass autofahren läutet das studio auto
fahren
das heißt ja also hier selber nicht
grüßen sind das war richtig und dann so
leute jetzt gibt aber menschen
mittagessen hier eine sache nämlich
nicht wert ist
er ist so ein kranker bettler kollegen
die gerade eben schon fünf oder sechs
leckerlis gegeben ja das ist nicht genug
für mich schwere sachen mir egal gibt
nudeln zu zweit ein hilft und dann
wollen die menschen aber was essen los
er kommt und will haben
der mensch ist ja jetzt auch gegessen
währenddessen hat sie mir sein spielzeug
angebracht war so als kleinen anreiz
nach dem motto mensch wie mit mir ja
dann macht auch bewerfen so dass herrn
hat jetzt selber hat genug von den
faulen menschen
sebastian mit dem wir uns einsturz zu
bringen wer hat lust auf neues und
deswegen gehe ich jetzt raus wurde so
heißen sie müssen von einem park und ja
wirft doch endlich ja ja ich bin der
schnellste hat sogar leute hast du wärst
fc köln spielzeug guter und manchmal
haben wir schon gern so ein hund läuft
aber vor wenn einfach so dass geister im
leben ist dass man so ein leckerli
bekommt und dass irgendjemand einen
stock wirft für ein neues gehäuse hat
jetzt eine neue methode das gerade eben
die paar malerischen strecke geworfen
habe hat er einfach einfach den den
strick so einmal berührt so berührt
hatten also 20 meter von mir entfernt
hat einmal berührt und dann liegen
lassen so es ist nicht wie es
funktioniert okay daher versucht okay
aber es ist ein hund gekommen
das habe ich nicht so der fan von
anderen hunden aber das nicht okay
kollegah nächster versuch ich werfe und
du bringst dich okay nicht einmal
berühren dann liegen lassen bringen er
hat ihn sehr gut sehr gut er bringt ihn
das sind ja fliegen lassen
ich weiß ham gefallen und noch mal
das bisschen verwackelt immer wenn ich
werfe ich ja klar dass seine maschine
den nimmt da direkt auf marschall
einfach die maschine bei dir jetzt sagt
man einfach die maschine das ist jetzt
ja etwas weniger grip vielen sollte was
soll das lachen films du nicht etwa nein
ich fühle mich nicht keine sorge also
ist alles privat ja okay also ja wie
gesagt so ausgepowert und das haben wir
viele hunde spaß gehabt ist noch ein
bisschen menschen spaß mit jan buschmann
als was ist ein und dann schauen wir
weiter
jetzt noch ein bisschen fischer heute
ist übrigens gerade dem handy auch falls
er tun gerade bisher ausgeben der palast
handy ich habe mir gerade eben dass man
eis geholt und muss gemacht dass termin
gar nicht an
doch wo ich mach dich nicht anders
dachten aber er ist relativ normal damit
also die nudeln daneben waren deutlich
geil da für ihn so leute umgezogen zum
sporttreiben auch eingeladen
er war kein auto fahren ich habe hinten
im kofferraum 40 kilo an gewicht
die werde ich gleich auf zwei hanteln
packen und dann an einem offenen
durchlüfteten ort gemeinsam kumpel
natürlich sicherheitsabstand trainieren
davon wird in metz kraftsport die tage
aus und dann ist oft schwierig gewichte
einfach durch die gegend schleppen
müssen damit man an irgendeinem ort wo
man sich dann vielleicht mal auf halten
ab wenn wir so mehr oder weniger mehr
schlecht als recht der übung machen kann
hat es schon film in dem spot das ist im
kölner rheinauhafen habe mache jetzt
hier so behelfen wie sich unsere
klimmzüge hier oben haben wie gesagt die
250 kilo hanteln dabei für karls müssen
dann auch irgendwie eine bank oder so
gehen um dann rudern zu können also
einiges wurde ja man muss erfinderisch
landtage ganz wichtig leute so bei der
ganzen sache dass wir den qualifizierten
personal trainer des sc - hier dabei
haben der wird die ganzen übung
überwachen
mit dem fachlichen blick mit zwei
verschieden farbigen augen sieht man
nämlich noch besser auf die übung nicht
ausgeführt werden
das ist richtig
okay leute doktor sex im minus hat
darauf bestanden dass wir ihn von der
leyen abnehmen weil er und sonst nicht
richtig betreuen kann besser so herr dr
- wie finden sie die ausführung bisher
schlecht so wissen zurück vom trainings
war echt anstrengend sogar sam hat
bisschen platt gemacht
wir sind was ist los mit dir kollege
hättest du sozusagen die geräusche also
auf jeden fall leute eine sache die
richtig krass ist gerade eben hat das
gemacht was dir niemand wer hat sonst
immer so krass ist vom autofahren und
jetzt gerade eben bisher zum ersten mal
neben mir im auto eingeschlafen
währenddessen sogleich gekrault er war
so klappt dann ist einfach eingeschlafen
folge machte sonst niederzuschießen otto
aber diesmal ging es echt gut
und ja voll cool künstler wasserstand
leute weil da der videodatei fähig war
damit cent bei mir zu hause abgeholt und
auf einmal hat sam so richtig seltsame
geräusche gemacht ich dachte oh mein
gott was ist los bei dem würde jetzt
immer auf toilette im essen gestellt
gestellt so und hab ich meine mama
angerufen und seine mama meinte ja das
liegt daran dass sam nicht kastriert ist
und dass er jetzt gerade eine läufige
hündin riecht und deswegen gibt es kommt
stimmt nicht ich mache ja sonst beiße
ich dich ein bisschen bisschen bauch
kraulen hat sich gerade immer einfach so
nebenbei auf den rücken geworfen hatte
kollege macht jetzt nicht so leute wie
sie jetzt noch mal im park weil doktors
emssee - hat gesagt herr kollege hier
einmal am tag stopp werfen reicht nicht
und draußen seid doch mal vielleicht
reicht nicht nein wenn wir jetzt noch
mal also sehr gerne
ich erwarte dass man kann sich
unterhalten sich mittlerweile auch schon
11 uhr und glaube das sagt alles müssen
müde
ich habe es ja wie essen trinken
hingestellt der ist nämlich immer nachts
ich mir sagen lassen und hier drüben in
meinem bett im schlafzimmer schlafen
habe ich mit dem kleinen schlossplatz
gebaut dann von hand doch dann gehen wir
jetzt schlafen und wir sehen uns gleich
[Musik]
ich habe immer aufgestanden
da stand es schon so in meinem bett
machen ja bitte sofort ja ja ja leute
ganz vergessen hast ja auch noch erster
mai tag der arbeit nichts los in parks
linke mit den zähnen gleich mal ab und
wirkt hat ihm schon ein paar leckerlis
bekommt weile braver haben übung gemacht
und jetzt können wir veränderungen mit
dem gleichen stock noch ein bisschen
spielen er habe auch gestern noch mal
gegoogelt leute was bedeutet werden wenn
hunde eine ablenkung ich bin nicht ganz
sicher aber was ist was ist sein so
entstand das hier einerseits da nehme
mir was von einem fordern manchmal aber
dass sie meistens damit einfach liebe
ausdrücken welt ausdrücken dass man von
ihnen als rudelführer zitiert wird seit
gestern ausgiebig meine hände abgelegt
also wenn ich habe mir seine
zertifizierte rudelführer zertifiziert
der rudelführer so leute jetzt kommen zu
einem paar denen sich 85 prozent von den
leuten die auf ins programm geschrieben
habe was ich machen soll gewünscht haben
und zwar dass ihm einen trick beibringe
ich werde jetzt versuchen das einparken
beizubringen heißt das wenn ich so stehe
das amt von hinten kommt zwischen meine
beine geht und jetzt macht ich habe mir
dazu einmal youtube video angeschaut
deswegen schauen wir mal wie das
funktioniert zwar funktioniert es so als
allererstes dass ich habe meine tasche
und ich werde immer ein leckerli hinter
mich dann geht eher dahin und dann
reichlich so 1 durch meine beine durch
ja und nach drei vier läufen sollte das
handy kapieren dass nachdem der kalli
das hier kommt und das kombiniert dann
irgendwann im kommando zum beispiel
einpacken
und dann nehmen wir den fall geht es von
selbst eigentlich entsteht ist also ich
habe es ja eigentlich sehr telegen
deswegen schauen wir mal immer erst
jetzt 31 habt ihr es gefunden
okay das ganze weile probiert und geübte
problems jetzt mal einmal aus als
vorführung wir sind nicht ganz auf jeden
fall nicht perfekt aber wissen was sie
schon gelernt einparken wollte ein paar
tipps zum thema hunden tricks beibringen
hunde halten waterboarding kommentare
reinschreiben denkmal der ganzen sache
bitte auch dass ich eben nicht viel
erfahrung hat mit hunden und ja genau
erdenklichen rumänien habe so viele
leckerlis abgestorben wenn ich mich mal
gelernt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
so leute damit jetzt sagen wieder zurück
zu seiner mama und seiner wg familie ich
habe megaspaß kabinetts zum schreiben
kommt rein was ihr davon haltet und ob
ich mein hund holen sollte fest welche
rasse power ein bruder